anyway welcome to see you're playin
jokin I know what that means but I guess
so some Scotch opening
I really don't fare well with this
Vijaya did not yet get around she can
replace this line people nowadays know
that 95 is just a bit better most people
do it's not the that's not them the only
problem but the most serious one this is
normally quite a pain it's my experience
equal issue
d 5 completely equalizes but then you
have a bit of a hard time job too we had
to play for for anything and it's just
extremely extremely non confrontational
I'm trying this to have a little bit
more on the board what's this it's that
some tactic they're not do this I can
take on c6
doesn't really do all that much okay I
thought weekly form
doesn't work at least not fun advantage
maybe no do you play quality it's a bit
of shame that was my idea
mm-hmm okay yeah 35 maybe to put to get
a bit of a probably also not gradient
yeah you kind of heard maybe I can do
this to make it more interesting and
then upon closing suspection you say oh
man doesn't work then you have to play
something simple
[Music]
check
hmm it is probably still equal but
that's a little bit interesting now I
get 93
was he just going to play no rook d7 I
could have done calm down dad
covering the seventh and trying to take
now on a three is not going to be able
to keep all the pawns but that won't
work
okay this is a good move
trying to get your c7 hmm let's indeed a
good move okay it's not a big deal here
I think giving up the porn wasn't I
don't think it wasn't a risky decision
ya know night if for one idea for night
you for probably
c6 you might have night a7 just go right
in
[Music]
I'd be father also can play book to
detune huh I should stop what we're
looking and move like that it's a little
bit embarrassing
Yahoo t7 is probably going to go c5
actually it's that dangerous might be it
might be
but take this is just probably going to
take on v6 let's take this done
maybe just what check why was that
necessary
there's so lots not an easy win by any
means I still only have one pawn left
which is not so easy to win with I have
to really make sure that I'm not
dropping this pawn you'll be born
okay white resigns okay they blundered
in the ending I mean I was completely
equal position for most of the time yeah
so here I think this is just equal so
yeah I think it's just nothing going on
[Music]
t 7 was this was an interesting option
but this also didn't feel too bad
thank you for yeah I think the engine is
just spot-on and it just should be it
should be just equal yeah here I took a
while trying to think about things like
this but he can take care and I don't
really have a good move now I mean I
cannot take him promotes at the end I
decided to just take can f6
that Wallace e6 wasn't so great okay
this was bad I because I'm meeting him
he has got no discovered check okay so
essentially it was done they decided
things he I just have to be careful not
to to drop my B pawn is important you
know this was the easiest way to do it
yeah you know always fight even in very
very equal
positions just just try okay guys thanks
for watching